hi welcome back to my channel and today
I have this beautiful lady with me alia
Alia is our Pilates instructor on the
field fitness app and today we want to
focus on the core exactly so how you
guys I'm alia nice to see you guys again
so today's workout will be a core
intensive workout so right from the
start right from the beginning we're
gonna be working on stabilizing the core
and simultaneously strengthening it as
well
and it's a short ineffective and
sometimes difficult workout yeah so
we're gonna be here today to start
working and strengthening and activating
the core so if you're new to Pilates
don't worry about it because I'm new to
Pilate and she will be guiding us
through this entire workout and if you
want to have a firmer tummy well be sure
to do this workout
[Music]
all right now so the first exercise
you're going to be doing is called the
watchdog so again many of you if this
exercise may seem familiar but it's a
good warm-up exercise here so we're
gonna start our eye on our hands and
knees making sure your hands are
directly stacked underneath the
shoulders knees directly stuck
underneath the hips think about pressing
those hands away from each other and
also think about pulling those elbows
towards each other so you're definitely
working the pecs the serratus anterior
next really important cue you want to
make sure you don't drop the head so
it's constantly in line with a cervical
spine so watch dog we're just gonna take
a big inhale think about pressing those
fingertips on those hands away from the
mat as you exhale we are going to reach
the right arm and left leg out
simultaneously inhale to hold and exhale
to release back down
reset left side inhale to prepare exhale
reach left arm and right leg and release
back down again option you can either
have the toes curled under or flat
depending on what you're comfortable
with
let's do about three more times on each
side right arm and left leg slight the
arm forward and the leg back again you
want to avoid any rotation in those hips
and release to reset left arm and right
leg keeping the arm and the leg parallel
to the floor good two more on each side
keep breathing you guys
inhale legs will slide arms and leg off
squeeze those glutes pull the belly in
towards the spine and release back down
left arm right leg challenge yourself to
hold for a couple of seconds and release
so you're also working the obliques here
right arm left leg so the obliques are
gonna prevent you from rotating those
hips and the torso and gently release
back down
last one here left arm and right leg and
hold squeeze the glutes keep pushing the
hands away from the mat so you're not
collapsing into the shoulders and gently
bring the arm and then
than you guys so again generally
throughout this whole sequence of core
exercises you can either do about we're
doing about four sets each but ideally
about six to eight reps for each
exercise so the next exercise we're
gonna do is the short plank again this
is another familiar exercise that we've
done I think in one of my first few
videos so again same position on your
hands and knees and for the short plank
you want to make sure that you're
curling those toes under so there's no
option to have the feet flat
so from here keeping the legs about hip
distance apart nice neutral spine and
flatten those lower abdominals think
about shooting the tailbone out towards
the back of the room push your hands
away whenever you're ready inhale to
lengthen out through the crown of the
head exhale to just hover the knees off
a couple of inches maintaining that
neutral spine and then gently to lower
back those knees let's do that three
more inhale shoulders away from the ears
exhale to hover off again imagine that
you can basically place a little teacup
on top of your sacrum on your tailbone
without dropping it and back down two
more you guys are doing really good here
inhale exhale to lift again try not to
stick the bum up keeping those knees
slightly off just an inch or a couple of
inches and back down for the last one
here I want you guys to hold up for 10
seconds to challenge the abdominal
endurance a little bit more inhale
exhale hold for a ten nine eight imagine
wearing a corset and you're really
squeezing that corset seven six five
four
breathe three keep pulling the ABS in
two one
knees down gently push back into a shell
stretch again a lot of the work poor
sequencing that we're gonna be doing
today involves a lot on the wrists so
again don't forget to stretch out the
wrists in between the exercises so the
next exercise is a short plank - so
obviously it's going to be a little bit
more challenging a progression so I'm
just going to quickly demonstrate the
exercise your knees are
be off the only difference is you're
gonna reach that one leg up right leg up
so imagine you're stomping to make a
footprint off that right foot onto the
ceiling again avoid any rotation if you
find that that's too much what you can
do to modify is keep your knees on to
the mat or keep the range nice and small
alright so we're gonna have the knees
off for this inhale to prepare making
sure you're in a nice alignment in form
exhale to hover those knees off find
that nice neutral spine stabilize the
pelvis and now let's reach the right leg
footprint up with the ceiling well done
back down to the left and down three
more in each site you're doing great
right good exhale left squeeze those
boots two more on each side to the right
to the left don't forget you're still
wearing that corset one last time on
each side right bring that left knee
down a bit closer to the floor to the
mat one last time to the left here bring
that right knee closer to the mat
release that left leg lower it down
those knees gently and push back into a
shell stretch how are we feeling back
there good good
alright Charlie my good stretch out the
wrists really quickly good and you guys
really important that whenever you're in
all fours that you don't think it
between the shoulder blades because
that's gonna add unnecessary pressure
onto the wrist okay and by pushing away
from the mat you're alleviating that
that pain in that pressure alright next
exercise is our watch dog - so is this
telling Jo not this is probably the most
difficult exercise in this repertoire so
I'll give you guys a couple of
modifications as well don't worry about
it
so the exercise goes you're gonna hover
the knees off same as the first watch
dog and then you're gonna extend right
arm and left
like so it looks something like this and
gently backed up so what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna do one set let's try
to do two sets continuous and then take
a break and then continue to do another
- all right again modification keep
those knees on the mat to do their
regular watchdog the first exercise okay
so it takes a lot of concentration here
do try to find a fix spot on to the
floor don't let those eyes wander
because you're gonna lose your balance
okay so we roll out those shoulders take
a big breath making sure those knees are
apart curl those toes under
hover those knees stabilize reach right
arm left leg extending through the front
and the back and gently release left arm
right leg and back super tough even for
me right arm left leg hold gently lower
down getting a little wobbly here left
arm right leg hold place your hands and
your toes back knees down alright - or
set yes let me do this alright again you
guys for those who have been doing the
modification to begin with challenge
yourself here at leas do one step with
me with those knees off okay alright
cover those knees off working those
obliques abdominals drawn in towards the
back of the spine hover off right arm
left leg and then back down left arm
right leg well done one more each side
reach fingertips forward toes back
energy to those fingertips on those toes
left arm right leg back to Center keep
those knees off reset neutral spine
gently lower hum those needs
and push back into nice Child's Pose
knees apart toes together well done you
guys so we're done with all of our
exercises in the quarter pet position
yay unfortunately we're gonna go to our
plank series now to be specific we're
gonna do the elbow plank so I'm pretty
sure we've all done an elbow plank
before same principle applies to it to
an elbow plank in Pilates so you're
gonna come onto your elbows right here
whenever you're ready
you're gonna lift your knees off and
push back into a nice elbow plank again
try to bring your legs closer together
the closer your legs are the more
difficult the plant becomes and lower it
down those knees let's you got six more
yeah yeah so pull those kneecaps up push
those shoulders away from the mat still
wearing that corset squeeze those inner
thighs and abductors and glutes and back
down you got five more five more lift up
four five hold start feeling the shiver
is that pubic the belly back down pick
up the pace four four well done back
down four three try to bring those palms
the knuckles parallel to your elbows yes
that makes it more difficult
you're breaking the chain here open
chain good two more inhale lifts up to
bend the knees lift up and you're gonna
hold for five seconds five exhale four
exhale three and two knees down push
away are you breaking a sweat
today I'm trying to next variation you
guys we're gonna be working on from that
elbow plank and we're gonna add on a
little bit of a challenging stability in
coordination exercise so while you're in
that elbow plank you're gonna be
hovering off the right leg and hovering
off that left leg so as you reach one
leg back think about pointing the leg
back and again try not to let those hips
the bump hike up towards the sky all
right so let's do this
let's do about four times on each side
coming on to your elbows lift the knees
off again keeping the palms apart from
each other whenever you're ready let's
hover to lift that right leg off the mat
point that right foot and down making
sure there's equal weight distribution
left leg no rotation of the hips right
collarbone nice and wide and away from
the ears for those shoulders and left
you're so squeezing those inner thighs
and those glutes two more in each side
right so you want to think about you
long gating the spine think about
shooting the head forward one more time
on each side right and left last one
here lower down that left foot onto your
knees and push back well done
final exercise here and we're gonna be
lying face-up in your supine position so
this exercise sir is challenging for the
core but at the same time you want to
make sure that your form and alignment
is perfect or ideally perfect okay so
the exercise goes let's do it together
so let's are in a mutual spine first
bending both knees good you wanna have
your inner thighs meet together nice
neutral spine so again the initial spine
think about having a little blueberry
underneath the lower back hands by your
side or you can have a nice t position
if you have more support right there
okay or slightly narrow whatever is
comfortable for you from here you're
gonna come into a supported spine
imprinted spine
you're gonna squish that blueberry all
right so you're in a slight posterior
tilt here reach right leg up to a high
diagonal keeping that nice imprinted
spine keep those shoulders down left leg
adducted good from here
inhale you're gonna hinge to 90 degrees
exhale use those lower abdominals scoop
the belly in to roll the legs overhead
stay parallel to the floor from here if
you can depending on your hamstring
flexibility tap the toes down to at the
floor if not that's fine keep it there
like Johanna flex the foot
abduct them hip distance apart
Axl slowly start melting the spine down
bone by bone keeping the shoulders down
yes articulating the spine reach the
legs here starting position point those
legs three more you guys well done
inhale hinge 291st
exhale lower abdominals working the TA
transverse abdominus legs parallel to
the floor keep it pointed tap down lift
flex abduct hip distance apart exhale
slowly rolling down imagine you're
laying some pearl necklaces down onto
the mat yes and then circle to bring the
legs back in together you've got two
more inhale hinge
exhale scoop up to lift tap lift flex
abduct slowly rolling down through the
center of the body from the midline
delay those legs as much as you can
start rolling down yes yes you know what
I collapse like a hot potato avoid that
as much as you can
one more inhale to hinge exhale to lift
up tap flex open and start melting the
spine back down rolling down bone by
bone vertebra by vertebra legs back up
to a nice high diagonal bend the knees
bring the knees into your chest all
right so I think that's all that we can
cover for today again you have an option
to do the reverse where you start with
the legs abducted and you start peeling
the spine off the mat all right roll
over to one side and you guys are done
okay
how do you feel okay I feel like I
didn't just have a cold workout but it
was a total body work yeah yeah and
there's a lot of yep sorry to cut you
there's a lot of coordination
choreography involved but I can take it
slow yeah yeah correct because this is
not something that I'm used to doing but
it's a really good workout to challenge
and activate my core so I would
definitely be adding this into my
routine 15 minutes long okay let's do it
every day yes as [ __ ] you guys well
thank you thank you if you enjoyed this
class with alia be sure to check out a
lot more Pilates classes on the field
fitness app with alia and don't forget
to also hit the subscribe button give us
a thumbs up and let us know in the
comments below which was the toughest
pose yeah it was challenging but it was
a lot of fun and we will see you next
time